last week elon musk tweeted that his
company tesla would no longer accept
bitcoin
as payment for a car that announcement
caused bitcoin to instantaneously lose
almost 17 percent of its value
here to comment is a man who invested
his life savings in bitcoin
you know him from dozens of subreddits
bitrocket411
hey what's up conan so excited to be
here
and talk about bitcoin all right uh you
lost over a hundred thousand dollars
after
elon musk's tweet you must be furious no
the opposite absolutely not i'm happy to
dispel that rumor
actually what elon did is create an
opportunity
for crypto newbies like yourself to buy
the dip
buy the dip that's what you got to do as
we say
buy the dip as recently as april conan
one bitcoin
63 000 now it's
it's well i don't want to i don't want
to look right now but it's so affordable
conan
it's so affordable by the name okay good
i'm sorry i know how this works if
enough people buy the dip your coins
will regain their value that's the idea
yeah and then my my kids can go to
college and my wife won't leave me but
conan when you put it like that you make
me sound selfish all i want is for all
of us to you know have fun
ride bitcoin to the moon
do me a favor would you take me off that
rocket i am not going to the moon
oh i don't know i don't want to be on a
rocket but
conan this is a once in a daytime
opportunity to buy an imaginary
commodity at a very low price
okay i'm i'm not interested well conan
listen this is incredible since our
discussion began a minute ago
bitcoin became oh 20
more affordable i just you know let me
just do a quick refi on my house
don't do that don't do that and then i
can buy 10 000 more
done and [ __ ] now i'm down 18k
which is a good thing because now i can
buy two more
coins if i can just sell my kidney
that's all i have to do is just
well you heard it here by the dip we'll
take a little break right now
hey timothy oliphant is here so you went
there nina
can you you have a huge staff there cody
someone's gotta need a kidney
20 000. put it back put it back now
put it back